son rôle c'était quoi il était c'est
manifestant j'étais dans ce groupe de il
était dans le regret ou pas du tout ben
non il a rien fait Daniel excusez-moi
mais il a été relaxé parce que il n'y
avait pas assez de preuves les caméras
n'ont rien donné et il y a juste
Jean-Baptiste trogneux l'agresser qui
l'a reconnu comme le donnant des coups
et donc c'est pas assez de preuve c'est
pour ça qu'il a été relaxé si j'ai bien
compris tout ce qu'on a dit aujourd'hui
ben c'est le principe de l'innocence oui
effectivement bah non
c'est bien lui qui a été arrêté
aujourd'hui
celui qui a été relaxé hier et voilà il
s'est fait arrêter aujourd'hui à la
manif avec une avant parler ça dans un
instant on en ont pas trop vite on n'est
pas sur RFM ici
bon alors il vous allez vite parce que
vous avez pas le temps nous ici on a le
temps voilà votre client était donc le
seul relaxé
vous étiez vous étiez content de la
décision bien sûr comment ne pas l'être
surtout que les réquisitions étaient
assez
conséquente elles étaient lourde même un
peu inhabituelle pour pas dire plus dans
ce type d'affaires et bien sûr je suis
content que le tribunal est décédé
aucune pression il était en détention
provisoire depuis un mois trois semaines
oui à peu près oui avec les autres
boutiques que la procédure était
anormalement rapide
cette procédure est rapide c'est la
procédure qu'on appelle de comparution
immédiate et ça aurait été pour tout le
monde ça aurait été ce serait bien que
dans de tels dans de tels affaires de
violence en réunion certes mais légère
ne nous méprenons pas on utilise à
chaque fois cette procédure ou qu'on
utilise jamais si vous voulez parce que
là
et simple parce que on les a pris entre
guillemets sur le fait je vais vous dire
alors vous voilà excusez-moi Valérie
encore une fois pour vous les enquêtes
comme ça vous avez toujours des
circonstances naturelles que les
enquêtes sont toujours rapides et
simples pour vous on parle on va pas
parler de d'autres affaires vous avez
dit qu'il fallait une enquête beaucoup
plus poussée alors qu'on était sûr de la
plupart ou du présumé coupable donc on
va pas en parler encore ici là vous
évoquez un cas de meurtre là on parle
d'une
des gens qui
les chéris on a eu des quatre violences
même sur des manifs avec le boxeur etc
je suis désolé ça a été également non
non c'était beaucoup moins long beaucoup
plus long je suis désolé Valérie
excusez-moi mais une fois de plus voilà
je suis pas d'accord avec vous oui
Gilles bon là je pense que je suis pas
totalement d'accord avec vous Valéry je
pensais très vite parce que c'était
quasiment un procès politique mais c'est
normal on peut pas je savais très bien
en vrai bien sûr bien sûr donc les les
avocats notamment vous mettre vous avez
réussi en quelque sorte en faire un
procès politique c'est aussi pour ça je
pense que votre client a été acquitté
moi j'ai une question est-ce que votre
client qui a été relaxé
avait bien été condamné précédemment
pour violence conjugale et menaces du
tout il a été condamné une fois pour le
tribunal pour quand il était mineur oui
il y avait une vague de bagarre dans un
collège avec une petite amie enfin je
sais pas plus je sais pas son avocat à
l'époque il avait
pas 16 ans d'accord il a été condamné
une deuxième fois pour le tribunal pour
enfants pour avoir
faut avoir jeté je crois une mode de
terre à l'occasion d'une manifestation
dans le cadre de c'est quoi l'histoire
j'ai vu qu'il y avait un un des avocats
qui disait
les chocolats étaient trop chers
qui n'est pas recevable mais un des
arguments des trois hommes en disant on
n'a pas attaqué parce que c'est la
famille de Brigitte Macron et de
Monsieur Macron mais c'est parce que ce
chocolatier vend trop cher et donc c'est
inaccessible pour nous voilà ça a été un
des argument aussi ça peut être un axe
de défense ça parce que c'est
d'ailleurs celui qui a dit ça qui était
le plus impliqué du moins celui qui a
été condamné le plus lourdement dans le
dossier mais il était quand il a dit ça
déjà en garde à vue dans la provocation
c'est évidemment pas pour ça que
d'ailleurs à l'époque de sa première
déposition c'était pas les chocolats que
tu es trop cher c'était les macarons
c'est du grand n'importe quoi on devient
d'accord juste est-ce qu'il regrette
votre client il regrettent rien parce
qu'il a rien fait mais sérieusement ou
pas ce qu'on fait l'autre parce qu'il
était dans le groupe mais non par
rapport à ça mais bien entendu attendez
moi je l'ai vu hier matin à la maison
d'arrêt on le process qui est assez
normal si un garçon qui a fondu en
l'herbe qui s'écroulait en disant
j'aurais jamais dû faire cette connerie
là sous-entendu d'être il a dit ça
d'être présent il était à la
manifestation avec une arme il va
pleurer encore alors l'arme moi j'en
sais pas plus que vous du dossier
visiblement un peu moins parce que la
remontée ce serait un casque voyez-vous
et une paire de gants
mettre un casque c'est une arme genre
destination on est sur cette tête pour
se protéger par exemple on est pas une
comment vous expliquer quand même que
histoire relaxé le lendemain il a une
manifestation comme ça avec une arme et
l'inconscient nous a provocation c'est
pas de la provocation mais c'est de
l'inconscience de de la bêtise
certainement j'étais duc de ça parce que
il faut dire qu'il détonnait par rapport
aux autres alors ensemble des autres
dont certains que vous avez reçu sur ce
plateau il y avait pas exactement le le
même loup qu'on dirait la même
c'est-à-dire que c'est quelqu'un qui
présentait bien qui avait toutes ses
dents pardon de dire ça pour les autres
mais non mais ça veut dire c'était pas
les autres à l'évidence à l'évidence
les gars non attendez s'il vous plaît
mettre comment ils sont venus ici c'est
moi ce que je leur ai dit aussi je leur
ai dit franchement vous avez pas l'air
de loubard mais moi je leur avais dit
donc il faut arrêter ils étaient très
les garçons qui étaient là ils avaient
un peu méprisants
n'importe les looks les looks ça veut
rien dire pour avoir un mec et les plus
gros escrocs c'est les mecs costumes je
vous le dis donc et quand toutes leurs
dents et qui sont bien coiffés bien
poignées et c'est les mecs qui étaient
les plus grands escrocs j'en connais
beaucoup
différents pardon quoi
mais vous êtes dans la vérité les mecs
là les mecs là vous dites n'importe quoi
excusez-moi de vous dire ça vous dites
n'importe quoi
que je rencontre dans la rue je suis
désolé je suis pas d'accord avec vous
excusez-moi
parce que moi je déteste mon fameux
prison avec des gens comme ça simplement
c'est vrai qu'il y en a par exemple qui
est considéré comme qui handicapé parce
qu'il est très mais il y a des millions
de très malheureusement en France donc
c'est pas du tout voilà c'est pas
méprisant
qu'il a donné je pense qu'il a presque
donné sérieusement en fait ce sont des
gens voilà qui n'ont pas les paroles
pour s'exprimer
s'exprime par la violence
ils n'ont pas les moyens de circuler par
la parole ils expriment par la violence
qui tapent les autres vous délivrez
en train de mépriser des gens bien sûr
été condamnés parce qu'ils sont
responsables de leurs actes ce qu'on
veut et là dire que ce sont des gens qui
sont illettrés et dentés je ne sais quoi
c'est pour ça d'un mépris incroyable
ils sont condamnés ils sont retournés en
prison ils sont condamnés légitime
arrêter de leur taper dessus quoi
moi en tant que spectateur je n'ai pas
là je regardais à la télé je les ai vu
je me jetais pour lescendants
mettre donc vous vouliez dire
je voulais dire qu'on peut être coupable
et marginal oui bah oui ils ont été
condamnés ça les option ou pas c'est pas
méprisant de dire que ces gens dans leur
ensemble ce que vous avez reçu à 15
jours ceux qui ont été condamnés hier et
qui sont pas les mêmes d'ailleurs hein
sont plus des marginaux effectivement
sans formation son boulot pour certains
il y a des difficultés sociales que ça
peut générer des gens plus qui ont pas
de formation qui sont pardon c'est pas
méprises non plus mais pour ça sous un
régime de protection si tu Ratel etc et
voilà ce sont pas ce sont ces gens là ce
sont pas des militants politiques votre
client c'est c'est Adrien c'est Adrien
parce que le procureur avec avec trois
ans et demi 3 ans et demi de prison à
faire malencontre d'un certain Yohan
deux ans et demi à l'encontre de Florian
et un an et demi à l'encontre d'Adrien
des lançons une agression gratuite
violente et grave et il a dit ce que je
crains c'est qu'on se retrouve dans
quelques années devant une cour
d'assises parce qu'on n'aura pas pu les
empêcher de causer des faits plus graves
ça c'est important ce qu'il a dit
exactement et ça vous pensez que ce qui
parce que le lendemain on le retrouve
avec une arme dans une procureur pour
vous arrêter il a raison désolé elle a
raison
il était bon jusqu'à un certain point il
a été bon effectivement sur le lendemain
on le retrouve avec sur la Wii attendez
c'est votre client en plus ne me dites
pas qu'il a recommencé mais jusqu'à
preuve du contraire il est arrêté quand
même il s'est arrêté et alors ça peut
nous amener ah c'est très frais
non mais c'est libre de manifester
pour d'autres raisons avant la
manifestation peut-être parce qu'on peut
pas exclure non plus l'hypothèse qui
soit fait arrêter allez je vais parce
qu'il y a
[Musique]
strictement rien je veux pas dire de
bêtises ce que je vous dis c'est qu'il a
été relaxé hier
restera innocence
qu'il a fait une énorme
ânerie d'aller à cette manifestation
aujourd'hui bien sûr
qu'on soit coupable ou pas qu'on soit
quitté au bénéfice du doute parce qu'on
a rien fait il y a les appels il est 10
jours le monde va passer crouler ni le
régime politique changer en France si
pendant 10 jours il regarde des pardon
pas des séries télé mais votre mission
plutôt que plutôt que d'aller manifester
ce serait quand même c'est quand même
moindre des choses il a voulu aller
faire le malin Paris ceci étant il
demeure présumé inoffensive il faut pas
hurler voilà il faut pas hurler avec les
loups son passage en prison il a calmé
ou pas
je sais pas c'était le premier
apparemment aucune excuse pour la
victime mais bien entendu
mais bon
je suis désolé d'avoir fait ça je
regrette le problème il a pas fait il
était là bah il était là il a assisté
les gars c'est inadmissible je me voilà
je me désolidarise deux et j'aurais
peut-être dû
c'est vrai le fait qu'il y ait pas
d'excuse quand même ça accrédite la
thèse du militantisme politique
contrairement à ce que vous dites
la thèse de ils l'ont tapé parce qu'il
savait que tu nous retrouvons à la
manifestation aujourd'hui avec un casque
etc et c'est un anti Macron et est-ce
qu'il n'a pas voulu taper sur la famille
de Brigitte Macron je vous pose la
question je ne sais pas je réponds les
yeux dans les yeux ce qui est constant
musicalement c'est qu'il a pas tapé et
je connais peu d'innocents qui
s'excusent voilà
est-ce qu'il n'a pas été relaxé tout
simplement parce qu'il avait un très bon
avocat si probablement ça a dû jouer un
nouveau ballon pas la face oui bien
entendu merci
c'est peut-être ça aussi je sais pas on
a on a tous été bon et c'est lui qui
avait porté un brassard orange presse et
se disant journaliste indépendant sur
Tik Tok oui oui oui oui oui
bien entendu
la presse et je demande confirmation de
votre part
j'aime bien j'aime bien mettre parce que
il dit des choses et lui il a dit il
aurait pas dû aller à la manif non mais
franchement elle est bien emmerder
c'est débile bien sûr
comment je vais me sortir de là
c'est un peu ça
encore là j'ai surtout alors c'est
peut-être un espèce d'orgueil mal placé
mais j'ai surtout peur vous voyez très
très frangin surtout peur d'avoir
peut-être été la duc de ce garçon je
sais pas je ne sais pas mais c'est ça
fait partie de l'avocat la culture du
doute hein tu vois je reviens ce que
vous êtes tout à l'heure avant qu'on est
pas dérapé mais qu'on est enseigné sur
le sur le mépris etc sur l'apparence
physique des uns des autres ce que je
dis et ce qui rejoint ce que je viens de
vous dire là c'est qu'effectivement
physiquement vestimentairement dans sa
façon de parler il dénotait par rapport
aux autres mais c'est évident vous
ressemblez à Eric Dupond-Moretti mais en
darka
non vous êtes plutôt Eric Dupont super
gentil non mais c'est vrai non mais
sérieux
un petit peu
en tout cas bon il a été relaxé
franchement les autres le procès ils ont
dit quoi les les autres qui ont qui ont
attaqué
l'audience a duré que 4 h30 donc il
s'est dit beaucoup de choses ils ont
regretté ou pas il y a pas eu un mot
leur avocat parce que moi je comprends
la position du mien
c'est pas simple c'est un garçon qui a
23 ans qu'est-ce qui s'est dit sur les
deux qui ont été condamnés c'était très
froid c'est ça c'est pour ça aussi
qu'ils ont pris de la prison ferme et
qu'ils ont retourné en prison c'est
qu'il y a pas eu de compassion il y a eu
rien aucune compassion vous confirmez il
y a eu oui alors le chocolat est cher là
ça fait pas ça c'est de la provocation
de la part de ce liquide
c'est quand même la sévérité voilà vous
allez pas critiquer vos confrères et la
sévérité de leur peine parce qu'ils sont
retournés quand même en prison et aussi
du au manque total d'empathie pour la
victoire
le diable se niche dans les détails ils
sont pas retournés en prison ils sont
restés en prison
et là on revient au choix de la
procédure de la rapidité etc
pour des violences même en réunion sans
arme en l'occurrence qui entraîne une
incapacité de travail de quatre jours
c'est rien c'est c'est moins que 90% des
violences conjugales ou des cas de
violence qui sont comparées
on peut pas comparer mais on peut
comparer avec ce que j'ai dit
permettez-moi juste de terminer par cet
exemple hier à l'occasion de la
plaidoirie je me suis permis d'ouvrir le
Courrier Picard du 18 mai qui rendait
compte de la précédente audience où le
procureur de la République avait dit
donc je serai là histoire de fermeté
louable critiquable mes lois dans
l'absolique la justice sera la même
partout pour tous pour tout vous fêtez
j'en termine vous feuilletez ce journal
et arriver à la page 10 vous voyez qu'un
autre commerçant du réalisme de son état
a été roué de coup par un client vert
tel cassé hospitalisé ni été
vraisemblablement supérieur à
4 jours et qui se termine par la Bonne
Nouvelle suivante son agresseur a été
interpellé
identifié et relâcher une heure après
le procès radio plus tard oui oui
il a pas débouché sur une détention
provisoire monsieur trogneux n'a pas
demandé de dommage et intérêt
c'est tout à son honneur il a demandé un
euro symbolique
c'est symbolique
tranquillité vous savez que d'autres
personnes du groupe sont rentrées de
nouveau dans la chocolaterie pour
insulter les vendeuses non si c'est
supportable ça non alors faut arrêter
c'est insupportable il y a il y a un de
vos invités il y a 15 jours que je
croise par hasard c'est pas gênant le
bras de la semaine dernière je suis pas
en conseil il est venu ici j'aurais
besoin de vous parce que j'ai une autre
une autre affaire sur le feu je dis mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait bah j'étais
arrêté hier parce que je suis allé à la
chocolaterie mais j'ai filmé
insupportable qu'il arrête et c'est
insupportable
c'est bon on est d'accord
ils ont pas besoin